you and kenny beatz got a crazy
chemistry uh i think kenny's probably
the most underrated producer in hip-hop
when we're just when we when we talk
about like the biggest following no his
following is insane shout out to twitch
because those twitch people are they're
a different type of dedicated
but
but he's he's a beast um talk about your
guys's just you know chemistry and how
did that relationship start man can't
even know each other for probably like
five years
and when he first started sending me
beats or playing me beats i ain't like
none of them
and he they were like similar to the
ones that he made right right now but
like they weren't exactly
of the same he hadn't had i guess
whatever lessons he got to get here he
didn't have those all the way
but then i heard his [ __ ] with key
the project and i was like damn
i want something it reminds you i only
know kenny yeah i wasn't thinking about
kenny beats because i don't even think
rory had introduced me something like
that right and it was like a while ago
so when i'm like bro i wanna get some
beasts from kenny beast he's like you
know there's kenny and i'm like that's
kenny
you're like yeah so i went and saw kenny
on the humble and i came back and i'm
like can you help me
and then
that's wild he was st he he [ __ ] with
my [ __ ] so he was enthused even like do
the [ __ ] we both tauruses so it'd be a
challenge it's a tourist connection yeah
i guess i guess it's more like a
we both like
a challenge